Hey youtubers it’s Charlie.
This week for my Series 8 bonus video I wanted
to talk about all the new characters we’ve
learned about so far there are about 12 total
but that number includes old characters coming
back.
There’s also been a lot of rumors about
the Master and Omega, but I’m going to focus
on the official people first.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I’m feeding out a steady diet of Doctor
Who videos while we wait for Series 8 to get
here.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
feel free to leave me suggestions for videos
to do in the comments.
So this is how I’m going to organize things.
I’ll talk about each new confirmed character
including Peter Capaldi and for each of them
I’ll say what’s been confirmed then list
some of the bigger rumors.
Like for instance the rumor that Peter Capaldi
isn’t really playing The Doctor, he’s
playing The Master in disguise.
I’m going to save details on the new episodes
for a separate video.
So let’s get started at the top
Number 1 is Peter Capaldi as The 12th Doctor
or the 13th depending on how you count The
War Doctor.
Here’s what’s been confirmed:
The BBC has announced Capaldi as The Doctor,
so barring any crazy plot twists he’ll complete
Series 8 with a regular Christmas Special.
There’s been no announcement as to Series
9, so we’ll have to wait to see if he stays
on.
There’s been a lot of talk about Moffat
departing whenever Capaldi departs.
But tentatively let’s assume they’ll both
be here through Series 9 next year.
Here are the big Capaldi Rumors: As I said
earlier, the biggest is that Capaldi really
is only staying for one series because he’s
actually secretly playing The Master just
disguising himself as The Doctor.
I think that’s rubbish just because we actually
saw the regeneration and the BBC specifically
said he was The Doctor.
Number 2: Jenna Louise Coleman as Clara Oswald
She’s also only been confirmed through Series
8, no word on Series 9 yet.
But primarily she’ll still have a warm relationship
with the new older Doctor.
Most of the on set pics of them show her in
generally good spirits.
The only rumor I’ve heard about her is that
she’ll depart at the end of this series.
I think it’s more likely that she’ll depart
when Capaldi departs.
So that the next Doctor will start with completely
new companions, just like when Matt Smith
became the new Doctor and he got Amy and Rory.
Number 3: Samuel Anderson as Danny Pink
A lot of sites are quoting him as a full on
companion, Rory style.
Like a companion that doesn’t board the
TARDIS right away, but later in the series
becomes more important.
Officially, the BBC has just called him a
new recurring character at Clara’s Coal
Hill School.
As another teacher.
Rumors: Here’s where it starts to get interesting,
there are so many people saying the Master
is coming back and just like in Series 3 with
Derek Jacobi.
Danny Pink is The Master in disguise.
We haven’t seen any footage of him yet,
so until then it’s going to be harder to
guess what his character arc is and if he
in fact is pretending to be someone he’s
not.
Master or no Master.
As for his relationship to Clara, I’m not
expecting him to be a love interest since
that’s kind of been done to death.
Based on what the producers and cast are saying,
Series 8 is going to be much darker and more
serious than the relationship comedy Doctor
Who turned into during Matt Smith’s run.
That doesn’t mean there won’t be romance,
it just means the story won’t revolve around
love triangles.
Number 4: Tony Way as Alfie
In case you don’t recognize him, he’s
playing Ser Dontos on Game of Thrones right
now.
Yay for crossovers.
In series 8 he’s appearing in Episode 1.
So he’ll be on right away once the series
starts.
It’s not a huge part but it ties into the
Jack The Ripper plot.
There aren’t any big rumors for his character
since it’s just a one off guest spot.
Number 5: Tom Riley as Robin Hood
This is part of the episode Mark Gatiss is
writing called Robots of Sherwood.
So you can understand why Riley is called
Robin Hood.
There were also a lot of pictures of Jenna
Louise Coleman wielding a bow and arrow in
a period costume too.
No rumors other than the Robots in this episode
might be the Clockwork Droids from Girl in
the Fireplace, since they’ve been rumored
to return.
Number 6: Ben Miller as an un-named Villain
The episode he’s starring in is one of the
two that Mark Gatiss is writing, we know one
of those is the Robin Hood episode, but we
don’t know what the other is.
Steven Moffat said that he would be playing
a “Storming good villain”.
I don’t know if that’s meant to be taken
literally as in weather storm or figuratively
as in a storm of robots a la Robots of Sherwood.
His casting annoucement was made the same
week as Tom Riley’s Robin Hood announcement
was made.
So for now let’s assume Miller’s villain
will appear in the Sherwood episode.
Rumors: No real rumors about his character.
He’s only around for one episode, so I didn’t
pay any attention to talk about him being
The Master.
Everyone is so sure The Master is coming back,
every time the BBC says a new actor with a
beard has been cast, people think it’s The
Master.
Number 7: Robert Goodman as Reg
His character will appear in episode 4 with
a bunch of other guest actors that were announced
when Samuel Anderson was cast.
Before Series 8, Goodman also starred on a
bunch of Doctor Who serials and played a monster
named Mandrel during the fourth Doctor’s
run.
No big rumors about him.
Number 8: Jonathan Bailey and Pippa Bennett
Warner are also guest characters in episode
4 but no info on who they’re playing.
Number 9: Keeley Hawes as Ms Delphox
We actually know a lot about her character.
She’ll be an evil banker and her episode
will take place in the distant future.
The big rumor is that because she’s such
an amazing actress, her character could secretly
be the Rani or even a female Master.
Number 10: Michael Smiley as Colonel Blue
He’ll be starring in episode 2, the second
of Ben Wheatley’s two episodes.
It seems like the episodes will be one big
story broken into two parts.
So he’s probably someone who will be helping
The Doctor, Clara and the Paternoster gang
solve the Jack The Ripper mystery that’s
rumored to be the basis for the story.
and last group of people Number 11: The Paternoster
Gang and Paul Hickey as Inspector Gregson.
Everyone knows Madame Vastra, Jenny and Strax,
but Paul Hickey’s Inspector Gregson character
was last seen in The Snowmen the 2012 Christmas
Special.
They’ll all be part of that first episode.
So that’s it for new characters so far.
Neil Gaiman did say he was creating a new
monster and we know about the titles and directors
for 9 of the 13 episodes.
But I’m going to save that for a future
video.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Be sure to leave suggestions for bonus Doctor
Who videos you want to see me do.
We still have a long long time before Series
8 premiere at the end of the summer.
I’m expecting it to start by August at the
latest.
Also since a lot of you ask me about when
I’m posting videos just follow me on social,
I usually give regular updates there.
The links are all down at the bottom of the
description.
Right now click here to learn more about My
top 10 picks for new Time Lords in the future
and click here for my top 10 scariest episodes
of Classic Who.
Thanks for watching.
See you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!